y aquí tenemos el número 35 el 3 está en
el lugar de las decenas lo que quiere
decir que representa un 30 o tres
decenas aquí tenemos una decena dos
grupos de diez y tres grupos de diez y
el 5 se encuentra en el lugar de las
unidades son cinco unidades que las
tenemos aquí uno dos tres cuatro cinco
ahora queremos tomar este 35 o estas
tres decenas y cinco unidades y les
queremos agregar un 66 unidades ya que
el 6 se encuentra en el lugar de las
unidades y aquí las tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6
6 unidades y los invitó a que pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolver esto por
su cuenta
sumen 35 6
pensemos en ello comencemos con las
unidades tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 unidades a
las que les quiero agregar 6 unidades a
que será igual todo esto junto
bueno pues 5 unidades más 6 unidades va
a ser igual a 11 unidades y aún sigo
teniendo tres decenas así que podemos
decir que tenemos tres decenas más 11
unidades escribimos el signo de más aquí
aquí tenemos un problema ya que no
podemos escribir un número de dos
dígitos en el lugar de las unidades o en
ningún otro lugar esto no puede ser 3 y
11 tiene que ser 3 decenas y 11 unidades
cómo puedo reescribir o reagrupar esto
de manera que tenga un solo dígito en el
lugar de las unidades solo debo de tener
un 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 ó 9 aquí pero no
este número de dos dígitos
uno pues podemos reagrupar podemos decir
oye tengo suficientes unidades aquí como
para completar una escena más tengo lo
suficiente para crear un nuevo grupo de
decenas por ejemplo puedo tomar estas
unidades de acá que son 10 y formar un
nuevo grupo de decenas una decena más
así que ponemos aquí un nuevo grupo de
10 que es lo que hice aquí bueno tomé
estas 10 unidades las junté y formé este
nuevo grupo de 10 una nueva decena y
ahora que tenemos ya que reagrupamos
esto así vemos que tenemos una dos tres
cuatro decenas
cuatro decenas y ahora cuántas unidades
tenemos son cuatro decenas más reagrupe
todas estas unidades y forme una decena
de manera que solamente me queda esta
unidad por lo que puedo escribir esto
como cuatro decenas más una unidad
tres decenas más once unidades es lo
mismo que tener cuatro decenas más una
unidad podemos reescribir esto como una
unidad y cuatro decenas como podríamos
obtener este resultado sin tener que
escribir como hicimos aquí cada una de
las unidades por separado que es lo que
deberíamos hacer mentalmente pero otra
forma de pensar en esto es decir que 56
va a ser igual a 11 11 unidades pero no
las puedo escribir directamente aquí así
que esto es lo mismo que decir que voy a
tener una decena más una unidad a veces
nos enseñan que 56 es 11 y llevamos una
que ponemos aquí pero en realidad lo que
estamos diciendo aquí es que 56 es una
decena más una unidad de hecho si
escribimos el número 11 vemos que tiene
un 1 en el lugar de las decenas y un 1
en el lugar de las unidades
una decena más una unidad así que sí 56
es 11 es lo mismo que decir que 56 es
igual a una decena más una unidad y aquí
sumamos nuestras decenas una decena más
tres decenas es igual a cuatro decenas
pero yo quiero que aprecien que es lo
que está sucediendo aquí no es sólo
decir ah bueno 5 6 11 aquí escribo un 1
y el otro 1 lo pongo acá esto lo hacemos
así porque estamos reagrupando estamos
reagrupando esta decena decimos bueno
puedo tomar 10 de estas unidades y
transformarlas en un nuevo grupo de 10
en una decena lo que me deja solo un 1
en el lugar de las unidades 1 en el
lugar de las unidades y las otras
unidades las pongo en otro grupo de 10